good morning everyone good morning Larry
oh good morning millenium oh are my
favorites Millennials today today I'm
good thanks for asking
you guys we have such a jam-packed show
for you I just realized yes okay so not
only do we have the fast I stores they
need to now before you wake up and smell
your own morning toast taste your own
morning toast take a bite morning Jay
been doing this for a while now no more
I'm thinking about did everyone do the
reading for today's class this is the
first time I'm a college graduate that
I've ever done the read a we assigned
some homework to all the toasters I hope
that you guys saw we posted in the group
and on our Instagram about the girl who
conned New York City Annabelle V that
will be our fifth story and we will be
getting all into that but then I just
realized I caught up on Mahoney we're
gonna talk about Mahoney and southern
charm last night was the craziest
episode of Bravo television since scary
Island really yes like people or
tweeting me like guys I don't watch
southern charm but I do and I'm I'm the
whole time like my stomach was hurting
and I I was literally
Zack was just like on his phone watching
the game and I was talking to the TV I
was like you're the pig so I can't wait
to talk about with that with you guys
and we gotta get Claudia to watch it
because just like dynasty you won't
regret it
no I know it's just like my plate is
really full I know but like get go for
seconds Claud you know I do love a
second dinner you do so and I will see
justice for the second dinner I'm having
two dinners tonight really Oh what are
you doing after Shabbat at home and then
I'm supposed to have dinner with them's
cousins were in from Israel but if I'm
tired I don't where are you guys gonna
go it depends if you go somewhere good
enough it's worth it yeah like Sarafina
ooh perfect
the trick to like if you like a meeting
or something or like something you don't
really want to go to is like set it at
like Serafina or like a dog or a
restaurant you really like and usually
like if it's a meeting like it's a very
alert yeah so it's really a free lunch
even though there's no such thing there
is by the way they're older I get the
more I understand that statement like
there is no such thing as a free lunch
except maybe like at work when they put
out free lunch but you're working for
them no that's not great you know that
all I can think of an instance where I
had a free lunch actually no I don't
know I don't know no you're always like
owed something in return
you've been just like your time I mean
to talk to these weenies you know yeah
but it's like an Adele B says you ever
someone ever do so many favors for you
that you only want to repay them in
silence yeah which by the way genius
Neph but it's one that's true and - what
a great way totally you know when you're
like bothering someone so much for
favours you're just like okay the best
you can do is like just nothing yeah
just thank them with your silence okay
well so can you believe it's June no I
really can't like I can't talk I knew
that I had this wedding May 31st May
31st May 31st like I I remember very few
things and that was one of them and I'm
like okay now that's over in its June
it's not so depressing and like we're
supposed to international like int oh my
god I know we really like we haven't
booked flights don't even know we booked
flights there but we have to move them
yeah it's a problem yeah and next week's
show will be only podcast episode so you
were hearing it out even if we are in
New York on Monday which we might not be
the studio is closed so it's a podcast
regardless Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday podcast podcast podcast
search the morning toast in your podcast
app subscribe so you don't miss it and
I'm actually available on soundcloud if
you even Android but if you have an
Android we probably look like this like
robots now we look normal to this
many of you're welcome enjoy these are
even though like truly justice for
Android users because like it's a better
phone like the technology proves it like
it has more features it's more advanced
it's more durable but like like how come
your pictures look like a World War two
documentary I don't know I don't know
but it looks like Dunkirk just cuz you
can dunk it underwater like doesn't know
we can do that too and I'd rather have
better pictures and a not waterproof
phone do we know color pretzel twins no
gogo geisha um I go to oh you know what
I did for the first time ever I did a
lamb squad manicure you know I actually
was thinking about doing that because
that's the level of ladies but after
doing a TaskRabbit to assemble a chair
that really just needed twist yeah I was
like I'll go get this manicure no I I
got home Theo shot a commercial
yesterday digital commercial the
commercial didn't shoot it they pretty
much gave up I named the dog that came
in before him was like so well trained
and it was for Petco and basically like
they're trying to show these new brand
of treats that they have so like they
needed the dog to sit next to a bag of
treats like that's never gonna happen
he was like attacking the bag he was
really embarrassing me like I wanted to
kill him no but like did they he did he
film it here yesterday yeah so like he
walks into the office today like he owns
the place
no see here I'll he just totally bombed
the digital commercial you know totally
he even left his brief he that should
[ __ ] he's a digital personality and his
mom is a digital personality and his
aunt so like I just expected more from a
legacy and it's had its CEO we're in a
surfer tourney he would be like I say
but he would be like the one that you
have to let in even though he's like oh
we like Hailee Steinfeld yeah but she
really turned it around for them
the Obul Tim times the clothes do not
make the man
good to know
is tainted lies and JDM - oh we have to
do I don't belong to you and you don't
belong to me hey Frieda I love that song
boy George or George Michael and its
Pride Month so it's only a propel that
every day this month we sing that song
oh that song specifically or a different
song Oh George Michael is just like a
gay icon and I love that song and I used
to sing freedom when was the first time
you heard that song as I know the first
time I heard that I don't know but the
first time I realized that I liked that
song was from the page perfect
commercial the first time I heard that
song it is in the scene of The Nanny
Diaries which like used to be my
favorite movie but hurt Alicia Keys move
out of their parents house in New Jersey
and move to the big city in the
convertible and they're like in the
carnival my nanny is just like one of
those movies that I've only seen like
bits and pieces I've I've never seen
really just like he's just not that into
you like at least yeah but he's just on
the ferry while just like Titanic until
I got alcohol poisoning in the Bahamas
it was the only thing on TV and that's
one night okay but it's just something
and she was like not that kind of movie
The Nanny Diaries it's like probably one
of the best movies and it's so you okay
she's an anthropologist it's so good
like hey and that's also what I learned
what where I learned what an
anthropologist is Scott D really wants
me to tell you that your eyebrows look
fabulous how do you see them I don't go
and they look the same as they do every
day but still I just same thing every
day but like I used I really been
growing into myself when it comes to
eyebrows you know what I mean
say like back in the day I just used to
get like random waxes at like Korean
nail places but now look I spent $78 on
my eyebrow teasing and it's so worth it
and I have major maintenance I tweeze
every day and I do a brow pencil and a
gel-like and I'm starting to move into
powder like I'm taking real good care of
my eyebrows um we get we go to the same
place to get our brows done and it's 80
dollars of wealth so it's you can
literally just take off my whole eyebrow
I'm like no one would really notice yeah
I feel like I finally reached a place of
like penciling in that I'm comfortable
with and that the people are comfortable
with
looks like skill and Instagram photos
like the flash back makes it look like I
don't know her but you know that's not
my thought maybe you get an Android and
you can wear them all no I can't and I
feel like I'm doing a pretty good job I
just posted look it's super cute
Instagram I'm like I didn't even get to
see the comments can you just give me a
that the best when you like post on
Instagram and genuinely forget about it
and then you come back to all of the
likes without any of the anxieties only
five comments can like some people like
leave comments on my Instagram please
you'll do that as homework for when we
close oh yeah okay so let's jump into
the past five stories that you need to
know before you take a bite out of your
morning toast
chomp so if nothing happened on
Wednesday a ton of stuff happened
yesterday
Oh today yes first being that Nikki
Bella and John Cena are back together
after calling off their wedding okay
I've someone to say say it sister I'm
seeing the commercials for total Bella's
and I think we were duped like this
seems so fake like okay the commercials
are like Nikki needs her friends now
more than ever and it's like okay I feel
like just total Bellas are like so
excited that their show is pertinent to
the situation that they're like you know
milking the cow for everything right
it's almost as if they orchestrated it
that's how impertinent it is but they
had a whole wedding planned did they
yeah how do you know that I know from
from inside sources I went to a
beautiful wedding last night did you
ever go to a wedding I did this on our
patreon episode I was talking about how
like I hate going to other peoples
weddings and I just like judge it and
I'm like oh my wedding was better but
this wedding was like so much better
than mine it was really beautiful and
and it's like I'm like a little jelly
why can't everyone win I feel like
weddings like why why is it a
competition why can't you have had an
amazing wedding and then go to another
mate pleasing we having eight months
later no it's like because you just
can't like someone always has the best
wedding and like for a while it was made
of like [ __ ] I feel like it's also
depending on the pertussis like Doody if
you are able to drink and you just
happen to have the best night of your
life like you and your dance partner
again but someone else like had to get
to work early the next morning and
didn't drink and it wasn't the best
wedding of their life that's real
subjective you guys based on personal
experience oh hey ed through Paula gist
I'm just you know there's something for
everyone I was gonna say something about
weddings and now I forget how do you
know that they're back together
Us Weekly has the scoop premiere that
everything has been through Us Weekly
but distance apart I totally agree and
like I know that because I you have been
reading the story and when I keep
posting it to Instagram every update
because we're literally like on the edge
of our chairs for these two I have to
cite Us Weekly because they have the
exclusive yeah every time so that's a
look
said it's almost as if it's orchestrated
that's yeah but I just don't think John
Cena would do that
no and John Cena wouldn't sell out to Us
Weekly thank you
but speaking of weekly magazines we're
in a magazine today we have to go pick
it up we're in OK Magazine
I'm so excited I won't get afraid like
it's no I'm getting rich so cute and
that wasn't a picture that was on Getty
Images no because if I smile it's like
yes I was thinking why is she so happy
but it was just cuz there were so many
flashbulbs than Betty and I just was
like I was actually smiling yeah and
that's when they chose that you know you
just can't take that sort of happiness
no you truly cannot so I'm pleased and
also I saw on the paycheck everyone
everyone else was doing toothy smiles I
think they wanted to like convey that
people works have another time ever
those raining but no we were having the
best the rain stopped for the overall
magazine no Us Weekly okay
just a month month and a half after
calling off their engagement Nikki Bella
and John Cena are back together thank
God Us Weekly can exclusively reveal
question mark the break was good for the
pair a source tells us for Bella
especially quote Nikki called off the
wedding earlier this month so she could
have more time to make a decision with
what she wanted in life and inside her
close to the pair tells us calling off
the wedding was the right decision at
the moment and their relationship only
grew from it it didn't mean that any
love was lost or that they lost any
feelings for one another but they have
both realized that they love each other
each other and want to be with one
another yeah so this article clearly
states that this breakup was really good
for Nikki because it increased the
ratings ever chef and like it made a key
put her in like a position of power in
the relationship because like he wanted
her back and right she was taking her
sweet time but this really gives me like
Charlotte and Trey MacDougal by okay
because Charlotte has to like reconcile
the fact that they're not gonna have a
family okay and so does Nikki Bella and
in the end Charlotte had to leave Trey
she never went back though no but Trey
wasn't willing didn't want to like take
her back and concede to having kids
yeah we're adopting he just didn't wanna
adopt kids where Charlotte would have
been happy young kids so I wonder where
they stand on family now Nikki and John
I wonder if she's changed his mind in
the month and a half being apart like he
was like I will give this woman a child
I don't know like what do you but like
why does he need to be convinced so much
like a child is a beautiful thing and
it's like it's
the world order like you reproduce
that's just like that's what you're born
to do every Bible everyone felt like
John Cena the world would be over yeah
and like the Bible mmm so there's
something weird about him no there's
something off for sure and like he makes
everyone likes like sign up he means
Nikki like sign all those contracts I
like living with him in stuff like what
is he he's freaky yeah but I thought for
a while that he might have been married
previously and has kids from a previous
marriage and I just didn't want to start
over I love Richard Burke and friends
but when I found that that wasn't true
I'm just like okay weirdo why don't you
want kids like there's nothing hotter to
me than like a man who's a dad do you
know what I mean yeah and like John Cena
as a dad oh my god think of that little
baby and his like huge arm big baby baby
I like big baby but like just think of
John Cena holding a baby like what's
cuter than that nothing no literally
nothing John Cena holding Thea Oh
anyways I'm so happy for these two and
I'm just glad that they're in tune with
what the public really wants for them so
even if they're not right for each other
they're doing it for us maybe and that's
enough for me this is from Juwan she
said he's afraid to lose all his money
because he pays for like his holes his
whole family's like lifestyle
he's rich as hell that's we come to rock
and go into movies like you're gonna be
fine and like Nikki Bella has her own
money I don't buy that
you know the successful laundry company
has like really good like teams and like
financial managers and and lawyers and
whatnot that that won't happen to him
yeah totally I don't and doesn't seem
like they have a really good lingerie
company yeah that's like 200 doesn't
Instagram followers this is a lot yeah
and then do get it could be indicative
of Chelsea no Andre no you don't wander
a couple birdy maybe just underwear but
like I get confused with birdy because
it's also the child
birdy be Bella's kids name is birdie
Bella Brie Bella yeah yeah her casein
Isabella brie her kids birthday and at
the same time they came out with birdie
lingerie yeah it's just really could be
anything else have a wine they do yeah
and it's like something with Bella which
is nice yeah I would like to support
their Instagram businesses me too
I would try their wine I feel like I
want to do there a lot of wines I want
to try I want to try Lauren Bushnell's
Rosa oh I tried it mouse can I try it's
delicious
cuz I'm on and off about Rosie I don't
like Alvers I'm getting more on it and
like I had a lunch meeting the other day
like someone ordered wine so I was like
okay and I wanted Rosie and like I felt
great then I had to get in the car and
then I felt tired and like headachy yeah
that's the problem with mine you either
have to like drink a few glasses one
just makes you feel confused ya know and
like I was on like a buzz for like a
minute of the lunch and then like me
better to drive out to Long Island I'm
like this is terrible and then like you
have to take a nap after horas or just
go to sleep go go I have so many come to
ok and I'm glad I have so many thoughts
cuz it took me a couple like almost five
episodes to get interested in this
season yeah it was slow to start for
sure are you ready for the next door hmm
Fetty WAPs surprises Milania Giudice is
album release there's just so much to
unpack in this way mine
Fetty WAPs no surprises but Milania
Giudice is album release it's just so
funny that there's now more than one
famous woman named Milania yeah first of
all second of all when you said Milania
Judaism like oh that's funny that sounds
like the name of Teresa's daughter but
it is right yes so here's what we let's
unpack unpack Milania Giudice released
an album first of all genre um we'll get
there okay she threw a party for her
album release as one does of course
that's all artist - Bravo was there
filming
oaep ik and Fetty WAP came to support
her and how was Fetty WAP connected to
the Giudices so I think she's a big fan
of his so Milania twelve celebrated her
album release on Wednesday night in
front of fans and Bravo cameras an
insider told pay checks on Thursday
we're told the rapper fat boy was there
with a special guest for the
up-and-coming artist
Fetty WAP is her idol the insider told
pay checks she idolizes him and he was
there like Milani and the 26 year old
Patterson born rapper was raised in New
Jersey he recently celebrated the birth
of his seventh child is he religious he
should talk to John Cena
milania's and
agoura posted a snap with him on her
Instagram story Teresa previously
supported her 17 year old auto Gia's
singing aspirations as she released a
risk a cover of britney Spears's circus
in 2013
okay first I want to say justice for Gia
because I feel like her her singing
career was derailed by her parents like
no it was derailed by that one
performance where she couldn't stop
crying by the way we must put that video
on her Instagram it's like the best
video of all time no wait it is but that
was just me and then I don't even
remember the rest cause she didn't sup
crying that's what gave her the itch and
then she did a group with her friends oh
we Katie right that was the best
oh it's season of joy its season of joy
like they could have been at least a
holiday song they could have been the
next fit harmony but two of them they
look too similar those three of them and
there was Gia and via and somebody is 4d
brow because her parents like her
serration of it all her family was going
through a lot and I feel like she really
had to step up to the plate and Isis
with her career on hold and then Melania
like comes in but I feel like Melania is
more cut out for it because she just
loves the spotlight I feel like
milania's work it out for she just loves
a spotlight totally so I'm happy for her
but I guess I still follow the fake
Milani on Twitter even though she's
looking out it's funny anymore yeah I
don't have a Twitter but if I did I
don't know it wasn't working like I
wasn't watching her hones and right
right so the live tweets weren't like
corresponding ones yeah with my
experience we've it's so funny that
you've released an album I must find
like it's gonna be on the show which is
just what we need
perfect perfect I'm I'm getting excited
for the next season number homes
wait don't you think it's weird that
like milania's like a 12 year old like
Italian girl from New Jersey and her
idol is Fetty WAP don't you think her
idol would be like Celine Dion I don't
know no I don't think it's weird okay I
do like that's just what kids do these
days
that's true I feel like I'm so out of
tune with the culture so it was like
your idol growing up Miley Cyrus I was
actually thinking about it last night
oh this is so weird that I was thinking
about this because I forget I was
looking at something on Instagram and
how you like stock on your favorite
stars on the explore page blah blah blah
and then I was singing like when I was
like gung-ho for Miley like the things I
used to do like to find out what she was
doing I mean yeah she's members used to
go to Starbucks everyday with Mandy
and her boyfriend Justin and they would
get like big frappuccinos and she would
just work it out but every single day
the paparazzi would take pictures they
literally had a tab on my laptop on my
Safari for like just Jerrod Miley Cyrus
search so that when I clicked end up to
go to refresh it was just the Miley
Cyrus page every publication so I owe it
like so that was Instagram for me ya
know I don't I don't really know who I
idolized like I loved the Jonas Brothers
like loved really yeah and I loved Jo
and me my friend Danielle like woke up
at like 6 a.m. till I go to some signing
and like we didn't even make it in I'm
trying to think who did you I was like I
think it was like too self-involved to
idolize anyone else yeah that sounds
right I guess so
no like when people like who did you
idolize like Olivia idolized insync like
Stan like when she was a kid like when
she was a teenager when she was
milania's age she's on there yeah I
guess
Margot loved Britney members she had a
birthday cake with Britney on I didn't
have that impersonator come tomorrow's
like I thought it was real because she
really looked like right now so like we
didn't know and she rides in a limo we
were like lean like new Britney Spears
from like the television and music
videos like we didn't know her so well
no when we also like but she arrived in
a limousine and we were like oh only
famous people come in limousines it was
so funny but like no I'm just trying to
think like who did I stand as a child
Dream Street baby down dream she let me
take you by the hand and walk it down
the Milky Way you know I don't know I
can't think of any I can't ever remember
like being on my laptop obsessing
looking for someone like Demi Lovato
where you went to her I'm like I loved
Hannah Montana but like not as much as
you a Margo Christina Aguilera no dances
I know that's like formative that stuff
I know it and it says a lot about who
you are
like in high school I was Miley Cyrus
like yeah I ever need to be like oh who
was I I just want you to listen I
actually loved Spice Girls and I love
that movie spice world but like still I
didn't wouldn't say it's like my Stan I
have to think about it for you it's like
we were like later in life
stand like one direction oh ho hardcore
hardcore but like I was too old to be
doing that was like the oldest person at
the One Direction 5 seconds of summer
[ __ ] so like if you had released an
album who would have been your dream
person right that's right Chang probably
the Jonas Brothers like okay that's fair
and that's a good one yeah like I
remember the Jonas Brother year like I
remember thinking when we were in it
like this is never gonna end
I know and then it did like so quickly
and I still feel like I thought that so
many times now about the Kardashians and
like it's never ending no I remember in
high school like we were really ahead of
the time like we we like to the
Kardashians before they were mainstream
episode like from season 1 we just like
them I think it was cause like the
family the sisters aspect we generated
to them in like that when it became like
so mainstream and like I felt annoyed
because like they were mine do you know
any mean like everyone took them from us
and I remember like at their height to
me or what I thought was their high was
when they were like doing appearances at
Cedars and we were lining up around the
block no but like I remember when like
people in our high school like my
friends started watching Kardashian's
I'm like I'm like get away like they're
mine do you know what I mean yeah well
now they're they literally belong to the
world yeah they don't they're not even
their own there they don't even belong
to themselves no that's so sad well that
actually is a great segue into our next
story which is that Kanye West hosts
listening party for an album yay at
Wyoming ranch with wife Kim campfires
and s'mores
Kanye's album came out this morning last
night and I haven't had a chance to
listen to it except for that first song
that like wasn't really a song and we
just listened to like 10 seconds like
more talkie and like honestly like when
I listen to songs for the first time
like they just sound like songs I'm
never like this is amazing yeah like I
need to listen to it a hundred more
times to decide if I actually like there
are a few songs where like the first
minute I know it's amazing you know what
song that is what's so weird that you
said that because I was just thinking
that over the weekend cuz Marga showed
me that song by Gabi Barrett and I was
like the first time like this is an
amazing song and I never have I'm like
every time I hear songs I'm like this
sucks but it's like with song well not
to insult cabbie Barrett I love it so
I'm gonna take with songs that are kind
of like doing something different or
like weird yeah takes a while that's
like a classic like gospel song yeah
there's nothing not to like about it so
I don't I wouldn't even know yet oh wow
my back my I've had something at 13% I
thought it was charging all that drama
drama but we'll be fine at this battery
lasts forever
um so even if I had listened to Kanye's
I wouldn't know by now if it no same but
like I actually really I'm not really
into rap I'm like I'm I'm really
starting to like really close myself off
so listening to anything about country
but I listen to the life of Pablo last
year and I just think it's amazing so
I'm actually really excited for that
song I'm actually like a rap fan now
like look at me and you like cardi B
love cardi B cry me straight something
can't tell me nothing yeah I wouldn't
consider myself a rap fan either but I
like honey's music I like Nicki Minaj
did you yeah I like really really liked
her she look kind of pisses me off just
like her attitude me too but like she
really is like she's really really good
you know that's why she has that
attitude you know and like she has the
attitude because she like as much as
she's like talented and like rich and
famous like she's a pioneer also she's
like the first female rapper like ever
okay I remember we said that once before
and apparently Lil Kim like oh that's
true that's true
she was before our time yeah I didn't
see her nipple at the Grammys right we
were I'm still in the womb reversely
yeah okay so Kanye is about to release
his long-awaited new album titled yay
and on Thursday Kanye gram arranged for
members of the media and select DJs to
fly by private jet to Wyoming for a
listening party with the great and good
of the music world turning out to
support the previously troubled star you
guys I thought he was broke how does he
flood people prod no he's not broke
after um like Apollo no after adidas oh
right and he's the opposite of broke now
yeah so that was just like a get I think
he was broke free today was before like
the check before the direct deposit hit
must be nice yeah
social media snap showed wife Kim
Kardashian if you've ever heard of her
is so supportive she's so supportive in
like they're so iconic and it's crazy
that like they're together that they are
together because she's like the the
greatest in her field he's the greatest
in his field and here they are
did you see the New York Post cover of
Kim I thought it was really me anyway so
mean like first of all like in her own
way she's like pathetically trying to
help and like what does she know
anything about pathetically she's doing
everything and she said just her her
presence it's like shedding a light on
this woman that she's trying to um part
in but like I don't know I just thought
it was so mean there was like so many
insults like regardless of how you feel
about the president if you like him if
you don't like him like she's just
trying to help him like it was so
pathetic when she showed up in like her
little pantsuit
like I just thought that was like it was
so mean and like but he's haughty
shaming or like just feel misogynistic
no one was even mean mean about the
present they were only being about care
and it's like but we love him ya know
like we we all agree we love Kim stop
kim seongju jenny big ass summit truck
me through like it was so mean and I
don't I thought one God for her son it I
just felt like she was already
uncomfortable I in the picture she looks
so awkward but like and then I think in
her heart lighting it does know in her
heart she was like I don't want to be
here but like I know I'm doing the right
thing and I don't think she thought the
backlash would be what it was and like I
just I felt really bad I thought it was
really sad I know I'm sure she expected
backlash but like not in that way like
just to insult her for the sake of
insulting her right they didn't say
anything substantial right and like what
she's doing is so honorable like yeah
she's going to bat for this woman like
that she just heard about on social nuts
I wonder do you think it's good like
she's gonna get her pardoned I don't
know I really hope so maybe hope so too
that would be so nice just be nice win
for Kim and the country and for the
country and for this woman yeah what's
with him
I forgot but did you see the letter that
she wrote her it was it was so sweet it
was so sweet
imagining stories so great imagine
you're in G I mean the lawyer comes and
tells you that Kim Kardashian is went to
the White House on your behalf
it is a dream it's a dream okay speaking
of down I'm so excited for the last
story oh wait Timmy finish the con you
know a huge time where the four hundred
people were there who were they uh if
you'd ever get stood behind a toaster in
our group lives in Wyoming and they all
went to a bar for a part of the album
listening party and it was like open to
the public she went in and she's got a
picture of come in oh my god that's so
cool and she said Wyoming looks amazing
I want to go Jackson Hole is supposed to
be like incredible but have you been
seeing like the pictures that Kim has
been posting no I mean like it just
looks so no yes so hallmark and there's
like whenever she's on the plane there's
still snow there which just I don't
understand yeah Jude no like snow makes
no sense I felt like no any what else
makes no sense like ski resorts with
like fake snow yeah like fake snow and
why would someone go why would a skier
go to a resort with fake snow and they
can go to a resort with real snow
totally
now that I'm a big skier yeah these are
the questions I'll have to wonder
attending the party alongside Kanye and
his wife were Jonah Hill and Chris Rock
on him too were rappers 2 Chainz ty
dolla sign Pusha T designer and Tom
Taylor and it was actor and comic Rock
who made the big announcement of the
title for the highly new highly
anticipated new album from easy which is
called yay
did you see the album cover I know what
is in it says I hate being bipolar it's
awesome yeah that's funny these pictures
are so fun wow that looks really fun I
wish we went I know I like sometimes get
FOMO from like the Kardashians with like
not as if I would sound to be invited
but like I felt like I was duped by not
being invited do you know I mean all the
time like their parties aren't on
another level
even when if it's just like a night in a
movie night movie right or like a pool
party totally let alone their wedding or
like their Mother's Day their Easter is
like with the Bowser house like just
looks like a dream a kid's birthday
everything Coachella if you could only
go to one Kardashian event
what would you pins Christmas party yeah
just because everyone's there everyone's
there and it's in her house like it's so
light
I know it's Chris's yeah he said Kim's I
said Chris's you said Kim you know I
said Kim Chris Chris's Christmas party
okay Christmas Christmas Christmas yeah
I would have said okay part two of the
story is that on one of Kanye's tracks
on his new album he mocks Tristan
Thompson for cheating on Chloe shook how
do you turn that around so there it goes
like this are you gonna wrap it no I'm
gonna like say it like beat poetry okay
yeah
poetry Jesus died for our sin
CEA's all these thoughts on Christian
mingle that's what almost got Tristan
single uh if you don't fall like him or
Kobe guarantee that [ __ ] gonna leave
you okay like rap is like so smart do
you know what I mean I'm always like
impress by like the the sleuthy like
digs in like dis tracks you knowing me
and 100% well our next story is about a
diss track is it Drake yeah are you
ready to jump right into the guy against
Drake I hurt push
Pusha T yes push a teeth who was at
Kanye's album release party but was
Drake there hold on I need to go back to
this and so I don't think Drake was her
but like jerrican Connie are friends no
I wish it was there I can't keep up I
cannot keep up I wonder if the they were
filming the album release party total or
not but Connie is like usually empty
stuff I feel like he has a new lease on
life ever since he kicked his addiction
and he's thinking clearly okay according
to him this last story
speaking of diss tracks is Drake has
been financially supporting the mother
of his alleged child enews has learned
new information about Drake's
relationship with Sophie Brousseau the
mother of his alleged child it was a
year ago that Sophie a former porn star
came forward claiming the Grammy winner
got her pregnant quote if it's Drake's
child which he doesn't believe it is
then he would do the right thing by the
child a record rate told us at the time
sophie has since giving birth to a son
named Adonis and even though drink Drake
hasn't taken a DNA test yet a source
tells enews that he has been financially
supporting Sophie through and after her
pregnancy I know that sounds shady
because like why would he readily be
financially supporting a porn star who's
pregnant with like a random man's baby
like it's totally knows in his heart
that it is but the insider ads that you
Drake is planning to take that DNA test
well he really should know like totally
and there's no need this is all true
shady you don't paint for someone's baby
unless you know it's your baby right he
doesn't even know this woman so this
came out because of his dish the dish
track that push of t released but push a
tear Alicia because Drake referenced
push a tease fiance Virginia Williams on
dubby freestyle so this is the wrap from
push a team another I haven't been
following this disc but what other piece
of slam poets okay let's go that's what
it should be called not diss tracks I'm
poetry yes so much better since you name
dropped my fiance
let him know who you choose as your
Beyonce Sophie knows better ask your
baby mother cleaned her up for IG but
the stench is on her a baby's involved
it's deeper than rap we talking
character let me keep up with the facts
you are hiding a child let that boy come
home
deadbeat mother [ __ ] playing Border
Patrol mmm that's part of it
Adonis is your son and he deserves more
than an adidas press run that's real
love that baby respect that girl forget
she's a porn star let her be your world
forget she's a porn star let her be your
world so dramatic
damn I don't keep like I need to start
keeping up there yeah so many diss
tracks me cardi B and excuse me Remy Ma
oh yeah and then like Meek Mill and
Drake and the end the means he like
performed at a festival and post like in
the background of his show where like
all of the mean means that people like
honey that was seven years ago that's
the only part I know I just love but
also you know what I'm also love it's
been celebrities reconcile reconcile
reconcile do you see Gabrielle Union and
Jada pinkett-smith wash their hands of
their feud they sat down like mature
women and just say we're like we don't
even remember why we don't like each
other it was years ago they were like we
were just petty and competitive okay and
I need a way to set an example
I need a referendum like that for Kim
and Taylor never gonna happen
like ever it's time I mean for me as a
stand of both parties it's time but for
them I just don't think it's right time
do you see on Taylor Swift ya know like
I was a kid I've seen Taylor Swift ever
since she came out I remember listening
to teardrops on my guitar in the purple
room where we grew up like I remember
but I was still like 14 like what
happened in my formative years I don't
remember
damn it'll hit me like but it's like you
couldn't have stand that math that much
of you can't even remember right now but
it will probably hit you who you are
like busy yeah I can't remember
Wow okay well for our fifth and final
story everyone please turn to page five
of the reading it's the cut comm search
an Adele ve if you are on your computer
and you want to follow along really well
out no because it is the longest thing
ever five hundred thousand words but
we'll do a synopsis okay
so there was a girl named Anna del V who
came to New York with hundred dollar
bills yeah I know
where she came from they just she made
it seem like she was just a squirrel who
money was no object she loved to spend
money on other people love to spend
money in general
she lived in hotels she was in of the
world tip generously yeah um no one
really like knew how she was rich but
they used to sumed you know she is
another person any people I know are
rich like they just have money right and
she's fine so it's like unless you hear
from her hometown like what she's from
Germany and it's like who's who would
ask but there were different iterations
of like wonderful people are like oh
she's a trust fund baby Oh her family's
big in Germany they're in oil like there
were different rumors but people didn't
care they were just like she's rich she
became like a socialite in like the art
fashion scene um and she was working on
this big project like this the whole
time the whole course of this article
she's working on this project where
she's basically trying to start a Soho
House type of membership club it's all
art based it has different galleries and
different installations and she's trying
to rent this building and it's so
expensive and she needs she has to wait
so she comes in Terry trusts her and
when she turns 25 so she was trying to
get a loan and that's where it starts to
unravel and but I think the most
interesting part about this is that the
source for the article is this woman
Neff
who was a receptionist or a concierge at
eleven Howard Hotel which is where Anna
was staying the whole time and they
became like really good friends and such
she would take her on trips and like all
this and and buy her clothes and go to
lunch and invite her out to dinners with
Macaulay Culkin and Martin shkreli
Martin shkreli like I can't but you know
it's so interesting to me about when was
this when was this
like when was her peak recently because
her Instagram like right he's very
fairly recent I would say she probably
was jailed up like around a year ago so
like all the pictures they were putting
in all the places they were referring to
like I think I'm a pretty like in the
know person like I didn't even know what
they were talking about besides like Art
Basel no they talked about mr. purple
they talked abouts Adele's
they talked about a few different hotels
no but I meant more like events and
people like I didn't know who they were
like taking BFA pictures of her with
like random people I was like who
artists you know they're not even cool
yeah but I think that's like an art yeah
of course I mean I think we're very like
you know in the know about everything
but art so it makes here's the thing if
we were in the know about art like we
would have sniffed her out oh my god I I
just think like was I ever in the same
room as her
honestly probably it's possible like
probably at like Soho yeah or they said
she went to Bowery and Paul's baby grin
like those are places I frequent and
what's crazy is like she you when you
hear the story you like assume it's like
a beautiful girl who just like has the
world at her fingertips and everyone
just like wants to like go to Morocco
with her and here's the secret she's
like no and it's she not like ugly but
she's not a beautiful girl
and she just like put on and everyone
now who's like reading into it like all
the think pieces are like it's a
sociological experiment about what rich
people only care about is other rich
people and if you leave me alone I can't
no it's just like no one is thinking so
much into it she's a very close friend
the best part is like when they found
her parents they like literally live on
a farm and they're like in Russia
they're like we are regular like we
don't have any money
like yeah we like paint her rent after
college like okay that's does not make a
millionaire but like where did she like
get this idea I don't know like what
movie did she watch that inspired her
catch me if you can it's Gabe was giving
me very catch weekend vibes well with
the wood she was depositing fake checks
into her own account so turns out the
way that she had gotten all this money
let me see if I can I don't even
understand it it's so in-depth and that
by the way she's in prison now and it's
gonna make for literally the best movie
ever that Neff who is a film
entrepreneur it's gonna make okay as it
turned out Anna's hotel bill she was
staying at different hotels around the
city and then would skip out once it hit
like 30,000 and she couldn't pay it and
then the hotel realized they didn't have
a credit card on for her because they
were just so extracted in this assumed
she had money right the hotel bills were
merely the first loose threads in a web
of fraudulent activity one that began to
unravel in November 2016 after she
submitted documents claiming a net worth
of 60 million pounds in Swiss accounts
to City National Bank in pursuit of a
twenty two million dollar loan they even
give 22 week the best part was that she
kept referring everyone to her financial
manager who had an aol.com email right
and they were like why does he even a
while back ami mil she's like it's a
family office family office what a great
answer great answer and it turns out
like it when they traced his phone
number to a burner phone bought in a
supermarket in New York
genius and the real guy like the guy
whose name she used like was I can be
reached for comment obviously she
probably breaking her man
I can't the following month she
submitted the same documents to fortress
an attempt to secure a twenty five
million dollar of a thirty five million
dollar loan after that Bank asked her
for a hundred thousand dollars to
perform due diligence she convinced a
representative at City national to
extend her a hundred thousand dollar
line of credit which she then wired to
fortress shows she got a loan in order
to use it as collateral for her other
big load I'm understanding it more now
as they read it I I was up I was like
keeping up with the article the entire
time until they started talking about
like how she actually stole the money
and like with the loans and stuff and I
was just like out of here but it was
like she was loaning millions of dollars
and then like just spending and I'm
tipping her overnight and buying that
for four hundred shirt then apparently
spooked by forth just his decision to
send representatives to Switzerland to
personally check her assets she withdrew
herself in the process halfway through
wiring the remaining fifty five thousand
dollars to a city bank account that
she's for quote personal expenses and
that's why shouldn't pay her bill at
eleven Howard shopping up forward by at
least Walker Apple and at a port a
according to New York District
Attorney's Office then in April she
deposited one hundred and sixty thousand
dollars worth of bad checks into the
same account managing towards draw
seventy thousand before they were
returned which is how she managed to pay
off eleven Howard and ostensibly by
Neffs
t-shirt the foreign dollar t-shirt and
the domain names of the managers at the
hotel when the managers threatened to
like call her out think she was like I'm
gonna buy the Joe name names for your
names like websites and like via like
Jackie I'll shred out home and then like
I don't know [ __ ] around yeah they
called me down to the office Knapp they
said Neff do you know about this and
they started dying laughing I thought it
was a bus move in May Anna convince the
company blade like every major company
is involved in this and they laid blade
like who we can't even get uh I couldn't
even get a paid for blade to charter her
a $35,000 jet to Omaha by sending them a
forest receipt for a wire transfer from
Deutsche Bank it might have helped that
she had had the business card of the CEO
who she'd met in passing at solar house
but who says he didn't actually know her
at all not wanting to leave Anna
homeless after their intervention last
summer the trainer and a friend agreed
to put Anna up at a hotel for one night
after having the hotel room removed the
minibar and giving strict instructions
not allowed not to allow
her any room service she's subsequently
checked into the Bowery Hotel for two
nights sending the hotel a receipt for a
wire transfer from Deutsche Bank that
never came
Rachel Williams city national and others
also received phony wire transfer seats
which a representative of the bank
identified as forged Anna's quote family
adviser the late Pete W henna key seems
to have been a fictional character his
cell phone number belonged to a
now-defunct burner phone from a
supermarket New York found okay wait
this is this is the worst part about it
Thank You Gianna chameleon the girl who
really got screwed is the girl from
Vanity Fair who put a $65,000 trip to
Marrakesh on her own credit card because
Ana couldn't pay for her company card
and that's literally what she makes in a
year
how was she gonna pay that back well now
that it's out there may be vanity
parable just like neither puts ability
or like get something out of it no I
that's what I really want to know like
what happened to that girl how much
trouble did she get in from accounting
also look at the corporate card lets you
charge sixty five thousand dollars when
we just have corporate cards back in the
day we literally contractor' like a
hundred dollars without like getting a
receipt having to prove late like no it
was like over $70 you had to keep the
receipt and like explain what every
penny must have so what if it's over
seventy thousand dollars do you know
what the protocol is then well most
corporate cards give you a limit like
even if you are booking travel and
whatever like you don't need more than
like $10 per month
cha-ching and it's like death was saying
how one time they went to dinner and
like Anna's all her credit cards weren't
working and so like never obviously
footed the bill would say more than she
would ever spend on the dinner but Anna
had spent so much on her and she knew
that Anna was like good for Julie the
super rich friend who's oh who took you
on trips and one time their credit card
didn't work like you wouldn't think 25
million yeah you would just be like oh
my god sorry
finally my turn to pay yeah thanks for
everything totally and then she got paid
back triple so Anne is in prison right
and Anna and f4 so friends Neff has been
ever since it's happened people have
found out as Instagram they found Neffs
Instagram and Neff said that she's
obviously working on making a movie
about it because she's like a filmmaker
I don't want to see her fail no man you
know I want I want to steal Berg version
I want to see Sofia Coppola's what so
you know her bang green what it was for
lesbian couple ah mother much Coppola
Sophia Coppola is version michio bling
ring yes starring well so people have
been throwing out some names
I heard Jennifer Lawrence I heard swash
a ronin oh I can't please the girl from
shameless who's also from Roseanne who
looks just like her
oh actually that's an amazing call
because she is like she's such a good
actress that I hate her do you don't
even like cuz she always plays annoying
characters that like I believe it and
you should I'd like an amazing call oh
my god that's an incredible uh but she's
not like cool enough to pull off like
the giving everyone a hundred dollars
you know what I mean yeah damn oh you
sent Amanda Seyfried that'd be good
she's I think she's a wide I think she's
a little too old no offense
Jennifer lunch would do a good job this
gives me like Molly's game vibes
yeah but she's young she couldn't get a
loan cuz she was under 25 like and uni
but it really is like 26 though no you
need a kid like someone who's small and
frail yeah but Emma Watson like but
let's go classic Emma Roberts yes yes
yeah but she's like too cool like I
don't know what she needs to be cool no
but like I don't know how it's just so
so crazy and now like people are trying
to figure out who people in the stores
are and I think Dakota Fanning yesterday
and I stand by that yeah mr. ko
defending it's not like conventionally
beautiful she's like different looking
and she's super young and small and
frail and very cool like I could see her
at the Bowery I could take L Fanning
yeah one of the Fanning's H everyone is
in Malabo okay let's break down new
houses in New York um did you did you
hear it feel my call about the
Nutcracker yes and Bethenny tweeted last
night that after I'm sure she saw the
episode that um during the put her in
touch with this guy who then went to the
end of the earth to get it drove eight
hours round-trip from Massachusetts to
bring it to her so like yes during the
main the connection but this guy did all
of them work like so I understand both
sides and I do think that Bethenny was
very grateful she definitely didn't say
things who were in that they did not say
the words thank you during the and like
in this crew like you you can't mince
words yeah um and I really am feeling
for Bethenny me too oh wow cos having a
nap and a seizure he when he's I mean up
sometimes you know that cos just right
now he's here because he's being so
[ __ ] good
speak and there's no Theo cam today
don't address it um your feeling for
Bethany I'm feeling for Bethany and I
just can't believe like the reckoning of
Bethany is coming right now
undeserved and her fight with Carol and
I know Bravo's Hagin every one side and
I know I feel like America has taken
Carol side but I'm team Bethany and I'm
not even someone who's obsessed with
Bethany I just feel like she didn't like
her Carol's priorities this summer were
totally different yes Carol is obsessed
with like being younger cutting her hair
do selfies going like on trips with
Tinsley and like being like a thirty
year old no totally and Bethany didn't I
forgot about that hard Bethany didn't
articulate that well enough she was just
like you're so self-absorbed that's not
what he didn't even taste all the work
she said like just selfie not like your
your which isn't an insult
no no but I'd love to take a summer to
be self-involved yeah it's not my
fashion and my hair yeah I would do that
and the marathon's never do that no I
don't he's not the marathon no but like
I've always been ready yes take the
summer yeah no no no I agree but that
was like she didn't say what she meant
and what she meant to say was that we're
on different levels right now like
you're really involved with like Tinsley
and like stupid [ __ ] and but that would
have been insulting too and I'm involved
in charity but like it's it's true like
their paths did not cross we knows okay
and when Bethany kept saying I don't
have a problem with Carol it's cause
like not at every moment in every
instance are you gonna be so close to
somebody bring everything together and I
think that's the way that they're both
trying to fix whatever's going on is
making it so much worse and the way that
like all the other girls are just like
reveling in it is and that's what that
they saying Ramona is literally it's
like so sneaky but Bethenny calling
Ramona to like start yelling at Ramona
like it's Ramona's fault like no it's
not Ramona's felt like yes Ramona's not
handling this with like grace and yes
she's enjoying her own but she's Ramona
and so like then Ramona actually had a
legitimate qualms with her and now
Bethenny's even more ostracized
I know and it's like it's it's happening
like a train wreck and I'm really upset
about it because I'm team Bethenny but
then it's like next week
LuAnn gets arrested and now everyone's
watching Luann's downfall and they're
living for that too so I think Bethenny
might get off the hook because by the
drama with the end of I didn't know that
this was the episode where they're gonna
address me so quickly and also they
didn't like they didn't pull a Bachelor
whether it's like any common and
yeah they're gonna show you simply the
ribbons did that for where she was in
her new apartment she's like I'm so
happy everything's I'm she's got a clean
slate cut - don't touch me
that video is insane insane countess
Houdini cuz she got out of the cops
that's crazy
that's crazy I didn't know that was like
an extra detail I didn't know no also I
feel like the more that you say that
you're happy like the unhappier you know
when she was saying I'm so happy I'm so
happy I was like okay so you're unhappy
cool no talking about how happy you are
it's like a surefire way to ensure
you're gonna be unhappy and like the
next five notes or that you are
currently unhappy yeah it's like people
who are happy don't have to talk about
how happy they're they're enjoying life
hide the fact that they're unhappy talk
about how happy they are 100% that's
such a classic Housewives move yeah I
could more watch a season the more I
just want to be friends with LuAnn like
before even all that's like just when
she arrived at the at Bethenny's
cocktail party like no one stood up to
degree there she's like no it's fine
John stand up why was everyone looking
amazing at the party Sonia looked 25 I
look love Sonia I love Sonja I've always
loved Sonja it's been difficult at times
but I'm so glad she's made it easier for
us again and her like revamping the
townhouse so many people are gonna say
they're like as a tourist attraction my
god jeonggi is brilliant and she needs
to put money in to make it good and
she's doing it and I'm really happy for
and I want her and Rocco to be together
yeah she's I met him oh yes I forgot a
public hotel right no Anna Moxie oh yeah
I have a picture with him
you do yes Zach made me Zach was the one
who spotted him and he was that's
Sonja's boyfriend I was like oh my god
and he made me take a picture with him
which I'm so glad I have to find the
picture and post it also you know what
he never spoke about American woman oh
my god yeah me and Jackie it got to go
to the screening of American women at
Soho House where Kyle in a very cool
fashion
rented out the theater ATS house and
then I'd like a little cocktail party
Faye Resnick was there Andy Cohen was
there but we can even see him and then
the screening was over at he bounds but
like I mean I saw him he was sitting
behind me the whole time so like he saw
the back of my head you know who's that
redhead he saw my maid bald spot yeah
I'm sure he just wasn't thinking
anything else this show is really good
and it's like so something I would watch
it's a very good show good for Kyle for
getting on the Paramount Network which
is the
you branded spike Network and it just
has like so many cool shows now they
like to reruns of friends they have
dropped the mic they have lip-sync
battle like Kyle's in with the cool kids
paramount yeah they also had to have
generator so they're not that cool but
they're still pretty cool yeah it's cool
it's cool now aside from the pedophilia
I think the show premiers in four days
I'm watching it yeah hooked we saw the
first episode it's really good it is and
what's her face Alicia Silverstone so
it's like it's so many instance in the
movie she's like giving me such cher
Horowitz vibes but it's like because
Alicia's like Cher's Horowitz isn't
Alicia Silverstone Alicia Silverstone in
sure I think it's hard to separate
that's just who she isn't and I loved it
and you guys did a good job in that like
I feel like there's a lot of people who
are not crippled by how popular their
one thing was like Jennifer Aniston will
never be anything other than Rachel
Green and like she can child she wants
to be in movies without on Sandler but
it's never gonna work out but Rachel
McAdams did a really good job if she
could have been Regina George stigmatize
but she kept working and like then she
had so many other iconic roles like Ali
from the notebook like so she did a
really good job of like not staying in
that rut which I'm happy for with
because just because she's a chameleon
reese witherspoon yeah she could have
been Elle Woods for ailments wait I'm
really hungry I want to leave but what's
on the tree do we have anything more to
say about Rurouni I had like a few oh
and you know what I noticed and in their
interviews Bethenny when Bethenny talks
about Carole she does so very delicate
really like a politician as if they're
friends now yeah
Carole rips into Bethenny and so I'm
sure Bethenny's watching this and their
friendship is completely over the blog
also Carole's saying you weren't here
Darren was a co-host did you read the
blog that yes oh my god it was so
[ __ ] rude it was so rude I'm telling
like a bridges have been burned and when
they were fighting another reason why
I'm tea Metheny is Carole starts
throwing in things that like Bethenny
said to her in confidence as your back
that's a loser yeah that was funny I
know and handled that just I [ __ ] love
LuAnn she's like you know if I'm a loser
I feel bad for everyone else which is
true yes also I I don't know much but I
know for certain that Carole didn't run
the marathon and Bethenny replied
Luann's a loser
no so I'm team Bethenny me too and
especially at like how are you taking
down a woman who
literally built a charity company
overnight and Llewyn like trying to
shame her for not getting by meanwhile
all the women showed up and none of them
gave because they all went to Mexico
that's here oh yeah that's why oh my
goodness that's what it's such a waste
of time till it was a little weird my
Bethenny sent to her assistant and like
the assistant was like hi LuAnn can I
speak and she keep like cash cards I
don't get the whole cash because like
Bethenny was like really couldn't go
like there's no way to spin it she could
not go Luann's gonna charity chamber no
I have cash cards [ __ ] yeah I'm hoping
of charity and this shoe Ilyas also it's
so funny because Bethenny like kind of
shamed every major charity when she said
like we went to Puerto Rico and not one
person had showed up no one had seen
anyone like that before so it's just
like charity trauma wait and then it was
the Red Cross doing the blood supply and
like who and trying to be like I went to
Florida and help the Red Cross and all
those press about it was like it's
giving me Dallas charity buys charity
world it's very competitive so that's
like Red Cross shaming it's just so good
you say you know that is so crazy nobody
can take down the Red Cross whether my
self Anthony Franco just the women
living for Carol's takedown in Bethany
they're like usually when we talk to
Bethenny we flounder we don't have the
words but Carol is crushing her I'm like
no she's not they literally can't even
figure out what day they fought on I
mean I to him I shan't I went we need to
talk about Southern time okay
I don't watch the show but like the
amount of tweets texts and like messages
I got about southern time last night are
like concerning what the hell happened
I need to get a copy because I need all
of that okay always this is what
happened
we had Ashley on her show yes and she's
dating Thomas we were fooled what we
were fooled so she came on her show she
was so she was so nice she was so
nervous and like I'm done dear Avis you
and I it started to make me see her
how she is on the show sort of sort of
made sense like when she's talking to
Kathryn at lunch
she's talking to my own minutes she's so
nervous that she's she's out here right
so I I don't know I felt for her a
little bit and I was like wow she really
wants the best for this this little
family and maybe she's the woman to
bring them all together Claudia they all
go to Hilton Head okay and it's actually
interesting because all of the girls
their best friends now like Chelsea who
came on the show because of Cameron
Naomi Kathryn and Danny who's chefs
expertly in years ago yeah Baird they're
all best friends out and then they all
dated at one point another the four boys
of the show so they call them the
break-up brunch but none of them are out
dating now so it's funny Chelsea dated
Jo me dated Craig Kathryn dated Thomas
Whitney Craig and Shep at one point and
Danni used to date chefs so like it's
this weird dynamic and then Thomas is
there with his new girlfriend and they
go to Hilton Head which by the way we
have to go it looks like a [ __ ] dream
of a dream okay
and first the boys go golfing the girls
go horseback riding Ashley's like just
being such a diva about the horseback
riding and a lot of the girls I grew up
horseback riding they're going along the
beach they're just they're not even
trotting they're walking and she's
freaking out and like they had to leave
early because she's being like which is
annoying so like they're suddenly a
weird dynamic cuz the girls are best
friends and like this girl is just out
there and then they go to dinner and I
think Kathryn sober now and compared to
Kathryn and Ashley must have been like
belligerent oh because she starts so
Katherine's two-year-old son Kevin's
planning a party for the son Kathryn
that's like no time with her kids by the
way because Thomas is so connected in
South Carolina he got the kids taken
away from her so now like every moment
that she has with her kids like she has
to beg Thomas oiling the dynamic is just
is really sad and Catherine's doing
everything that she can to like prove
that she is in a good place which she is
actually comes to her so you're having a
party with Percy and al-shater I spoken
to Thomas knowing that she wasn't
invited
she knows who wasn't actually yeah it's
like it's her choice throws all the
party yes so Ashley it's like trying to
round that way being like am I gonna be
invited and Kathryn is like I don't
think this is a conversation for this
table okay
and she's like what is it a conversation
for she literally starts this is her
with her hair she's being so crazy she's
like I see those kids more than you see
them like every mean thing you could
possibly say about someone like she was
like you had a spire the nanny which by
the way come turns out that because
their allegations that Thomas sexually
assaulted the nanny
oh [ __ ] and I think that's why Katherine
tried to get her fire because Kathryn
knew yeah and she was trying to save it
so literally it's so disgusting
Center the girls are like like going
wild people that can't believe the
things that she's saying none of the men
were that like saw it except for Whitney
thank God because he's like Thomas is
like everyone trust Whitney so when he
comes and tells the men like and you're
like you need to shut her up like what
she's saying is like so damaging talking
about like the court system she was like
when your son was in the hospital
you never even visited him and Kathryn
is like I wasn't allowed to yeah so
crazy then she goes off with Thomas and
the two of them I don't know what
they're on but they're like there's
nothing behind their eyes and yeah she's
doubling down on what she's saying to
Thomas and then they go into the bar and
she's just like if you proposed to me
tomorrow I'd say yes like being so crazy
crazy nightmare then they all go back to
the house so the next morning it's like
the girls are talking but they also even
say no saying the same house torture the
girls are talking and one of them was
like I almost feel bad for Ashley
because I of the pit that she's gonna
have this morning like right drunk right
and I was like you know oh my god
imagine waking up and you said all those
horrible things
she stands by them she wakes up of
course she's perfectly made up already
laying in bed with Thomas who's
obviously already showered so like and
she was like I I like she's playing the
victim like these girls are excluding me
blah blah blah it was out of control she
goes into the like breakfast room just
acting like everything's normal when she
meanwhile she fought with everyone mind
you on the ferry back from the dinner
from hell Thomas starts screaming at one
of the girls because one of the girls
was like if Kathryn is uncomfortable now
like with Ashley being in the house like
she can't stay in the house yeah and
Thomas oh my god Claudia like like the
craziest scariest man verbally abusive
man I've ever seen
you don't get to say who stays in the
house you had no power over that like
Claudia it was crazy so he owes her an
apology too it was it was really to go
up
he yelled at Chelsea who everyone loves
who everyone loves the next day they're
acting like nothing happened
everyone goes off does their own thing
they stay in the house together she's
like painting his toenails brush Ashley
is painting Thomas's toenails orange
brushing his hair with the Dora the
explora rush they're like so so bizarre
and he was like do you regret anything
that you said last night because he's
like trying to stand by her but also
like children yeah and he's also like my
employer right so he's like do you ever
got anything you said that's
she was like no no she was like I guess
I regret cursing I have even realized
she curse because I write because
everything else things that she was
saying anyways that night they all have
dinner and like Shep who gets along with
everyone like Ashley and Thomas have
isolated themselves he goes to sit down
with her and she's just being like the
worst person to me around like he says
something and she's like good talk good
talk like like it's like dangling before
the episode ended did Katherine's to
talk to Ashley again no okay and the way
we saw Ashley like we can never unsee it
and like she has been such a pariah now
that like Thomas has - they're just
together the whole time where Sir Thomas
is usually a social guy right with I've
already friends with everyone and so
like there's no way that he's gonna
continue with this like being with her
when she's but they're so right now and
together I don't understand and like
there's a million allegations about him
like being a sexual assault I also like
saw some rumors that he's been fired
from the show and like Ashley's
defending him in the comment section
saying that he's any press is good press
you're on I swear
and when Darren was here I asked her on
my point bike I'm like what's going on
with Thomas like she said it's very
possible that he could be fired like
they're taking it seriously
I wonder what's going on like in
Charleston because like he has custody
of those children but he also has so
much political powers sort of I don't
even understand that how can you pull it
up however like you'd literally went to
prison and you're on a reality show like
he's a joke but like the Ravenel Bridge
they literally go right into Hilton Head
and they drove through town called Ravan
oh that's so cool I'm jealous no it's so
creepy and like justice for Kathryn is
being served and I'm oh by the way while
Ashley screaming at her Kathryn is so
poised saying the worst possible things
you could say to someone like so below
the belt like legal legal [ __ ] yeah they
have a gag order that they're not
allowed to talk about their kids and she
is just like lips sealed like everyone
really turned the corner on her and
which I'm so bad cuz you know that I'm
yeah and then I was looking at
Patricia's Twitter because Patricia is
incredible yeah what does it call the
grand supreme
I don't know and now Trisha like
Patricia keeps like retweeting positive
things about Kathryn is like nice to
Kathryn when she was like so mean to her
so no I don't know i watch southern
charm
sturdy because when I was getting my
glam squad done like it was just on and
it was when they threw a bridal shower
for for Cameron at Patricia's house I'm
like why is this six year old lady a
character on the show like I don't
understand [ __ ] I don't like her like
she she's like they'll be some banner
come of the south and I feel like when
Andi like met her he was like oh my god
like you know hi takes a liking to like
Marisol yeah on Miami like that was
Patricia Nicole down to be that and yeah
and like Lady Gaga was her Oh does she
stop liking people that I don't like who
else
she loves the countess so like that's
all I care about Oh her Twitter name is
the countess you're on yeah Lady gaga
yeah oh she saw that Lady Gaga would
play the girl countess that's so funny
um anyways I feel like if you're bored
this weekend I really recommend you
start watching so I'm definitely know
what to this episode and what's so so
crazy like that I will never forget it's
like these two children who are like the
plot of a lot of this are born from the
show no they weren't if it weren't for
the pilot they really stuck together
exactly so like that's so crazy so to
see how far like everything's been
coming like it's just insane and I'm
really happy for Kevin because finally
everyone saw the Thomas the way she was
living wing and that has taken her
children away from her yeah and like I
just hope she now has like more time
with her kids same but like next week
looks crazy I just I can't and then
Chelsea and Austin for those of you who
watch like they're meant to be together
like I saw that too like they decided
last year that they both like each other
but then this year it's like it's not
working it's just like they want
different things it's like a Nikki Bella
John Cena situation sort of where it's
like she is like comfortable with who
she is like she doesn't she like drinks
and has a good time and it's just a
chill they're all but like he just got
famous and like coming out every night I
you said and like he's enjoying like
this life of like being a celebrity in
Charleston this is what I gather yeah
she doesn't want him just crawling into
bed at 3 a.m. like with her so she said
go do your own thing like I love you as
a person to well be friends but like
they're meant to be so much more like
they were being so cute and I just I
can't and he just started dating someone
like the week before they went on this
trip but it's just so clear that they're
meant to be together and I hope that
that's actually true and then like Naomi
and Craig like I still it will always
ship like a piece of like I believe like
Craig like he's our friend
I was a little bit of a weenie
on the show ya know do like the sewing
yeah it's but it's hilarious and like I
don't know I'm never I know Naomi has a
new boyfriend I'm really happy for her
but like I don't think her and Craig
like are an impossibility you know
nothing's impossible no nothing's
impossible especially on Bravo you guys
it's been an absolute pleasure hanging
out with you this week here's a reminder
the grand pooh-bah what does that mean
the term like the major the grand
pooh-bah we are going to be doing
podcast only episodes next week so make
sure you're following us on the podcast
app at the morning toast just search it
we're also available on soundcloud
episodes will probably be probably be up
around noon hopefully we're going to see
ma sorry I can't talk we're gonna in
Nashville next week so if you're in
Nashville you're coming to my show where
you're coming to our show it's gonna be
still lit we're also gonna CMA fest we
think we don't know what the hell we're
doing yeah well we know is that we will
be doing the show as a podcast every day
next week from God knows where yeah like
literally from another airplane
international like we might come back to
New York but we'll see just keep up with
us on Instagram and you'll know what's
what we're not very organized and that's
what's cool about us so it's like we're
gonna get to Nashville and we'll know if
we need to stay through the week exactly
you guys mature following the morning to
us on Facebook Instagram YouTube and in
the podcast app that way you get a
notification of every time I go live
which is Monday through Friday 10:30
a.m. Eastern Time we love all of our
toasters and we're always looking for
new ones so make sure you tell your
friends tell your family to join the
channel
join the Facebook group it's some
incredibly lit if you wanna if this
isn't enough for you with five episodes
a week isn't enough for you you can pay
$1 a month to get five extra episodes a
month and they're so lit their podcast
episodes they're funny they're cool
they're sad they're laugh they're more
from Fast Five to talk about other
people so we just have to talk matters
yeah it's really great for us so if
you're into that go to our patreon its
patreon calm /the morning toast I'm
Claudia a shy girl with no job if you
want to go comment on my Instagram I
post it in my kind of nervous about it
at girl with no Claud with no job
I'm Jackie Ashley Jackie O problem see
you guys I've already made all my dreams
come true with a hundred K I don't even
want a hundred um one I just want a
hundred for the rest of my life cool
until I get to insane so your job for
the weekend don't do anything we will
see you whatever
Monday sure